economía en directo América de France 24
Daniela en el estudio Daniela comenzamos
con noticias de Estados Unidos de última
hora fresquitas como nos gustan
Estados Unidos salió de la recesión
según la oficina de análisis económico
en el tercer trimestre el creció 0,6%
frente al segundo y 2,6% en términos
interanuales es decir frente al mismo
periodo del año pasado Wall Street lo
aplaude con su principal índice del dow
Johnson subiendo más del 1% al que
seguramente no le espera una buena
jornada es al nasdaq tecnológico que
abrió en rojo ya que metaplatforms que
es la matriz de empresas como Facebook
Instagram y WhatsApp entre otros pierden
la apertura más del 23% borrando de un
plumazo casi 80.000 millones de dólares
en capitalización bursátil o en su valor
en bolsa esto después de Mostrar
resultados financieros
impresionantes entre enero y septiembre
tuvo casi los mismos ingresos que el año
pasado pero sus utilidades se
desplomaron en 36%, debido a sus
inmensos gastos operativos pierde
entonces una cuarta un cuarto una cuarta
parte de su valor en bolsa en Europa las
bolsas se mueven al ritmo de la decisión
de hoy poco sorpresiva por parte del
Banco Central europeo de Elevar sus
tasas de interés en 0,75 puntos esto
para hacerle frente a una inflación
cercana al 10%. Dani y la acción de
Twitter será suspendida mañana viernes
Sí señor pues este viernes vence el
plazo para que ahí los mosca compre la
empresa sin ir a juicio y todo parece
indicar que El Magnate va a sellar su
compromiso por 44 mil millones de
dólares por lo que la bolsa de Nueva
York decidió evitar una sesión altamente
volátil y suspender la acción ayer
miércoles y los Moss quien ya figura en
Twitter como jefe tweet apareció en la
sede de la empresa en San Francisco
un lavamanos al tiempo que tuiteaba Let
that think o sea como decir
asimilenlo la principal preocupación es
que pasará con la compañía que
justamente Hoy está programada para
presentar sus resultados financieros del
tercer trimestre esto dice una lista de
Wall Street al respecto
Es probable que un Twitter propiedad de
Mask genere aún más caos los empleados
ya están preocupados por los despidos
masivos en la empresa y esa es una
preocupación válida ahora donde ocurren
esos recortes podría darnos una mejor
idea de lo que más pretende hacer con
Twitter
si por ejemplo decide reducir
significativamente el personal en la
división de anuncios eso podría indicar
que tiene la intención de cumplir su
promesa de reducir la dependencia de la
publicidad
pero Incluso si esos despidos no
ocurrieran el solo hecho de que mosque
esté planteando La idea es suficiente
para asustar algunos anunciantes ellos
quieren gastar su dinero publicita
empresas que consideran estables y eso
no es realmente lo que está pasando en
Twitter ahora mismo
hablemos de una polémica Dani El rapero
West que busca nuevos socios comerciales
pero le dan la espalda bueno hace un par
de días comentábamos aquí mismo como el
artista ahora conocido como y fue
titular mundial después de que Adidas
terminara su vínculo con él por sus
comentarios previos considerados
antisemitistas ya lo había hecho también
la marca de ropa Gap el miércoles el
cantante acudió a una de las oficinas
corporativas de la marca de calzado
Skechers en Los Ángeles y fue esta misma
empresa la que comunicó que lo hizo sin
previo aviso y sin invitación por lo que
dos de sus ejecutivos lo escoltaron a él
y a su grupo fuera del edificio Skechers
remarcó que no está considerando ni
tiene ninguna intención de trabajar con
West pues considera que sus recientes
comentarios son divisivos y tampoco
tolera el antisemitismo ni ninguna otra
forma de discurso de y le cerraron las
puertas Bolivia literalmente
literalmente
Bolivia Dani porque suspenderá
temporalmente las exportaciones de
algunos alimentos específicamente desde
Esta media noche del jueves suspenderá
las exportaciones de soya carne de res
azúcar aceite y harina entre otros Y es
que el presidente izquierdista Luis Arce
se ha enfrentado a protestas en todo el
país esta vez el turno es para la región
agrícola de Santa Cruz en los últimos
cinco días han protagonizado
manifestaciones que ya se tornaron
violentas para rechazar la decisión del
gobierno de retrasar para 2024 un censo
poblacional que estaba previsto para
2023 ellos creen que estos socava el
presupuesto de la región porque de ese
censo depende precisamente la asignación
de recursos
son cada 10 años que se hace
unos Avance en salud ni educación
los departamentos avanzan crecen en
población pero nos atrasamos en la salud
en educación en las carreteras Dani como
siempre Gracias por toda la información
mañana viernes más economía que nos
puede adelantar pendientes de Amazon y